what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things
mcu and today we have some new details
about spider-man 3.
some casting details about some old
characters that are going to be
returning and some new characters as if
we already didn't have enough
but the casting of these characters and
the description of these characters
actually give
us a lot to go off of as far as the plot
is concerned about spider-man 3.
in fact these casting calls give us a
little bit of an insight as far as how
it's going to go
now that peter parker's identity has
been revealed and the world knows that
he is spider-man
because despite the fact that this is
going to be an absolutely
insanely huge movie peter is still going
to have to deal with what happened at
the end of spider-man far from home
mysterio not only revealed his identity
but made him out to be a criminal and
murderer
and perhaps that's why the other
spider-man are going to come in from
other
different universes but we'll break it
all down in this video
and thank you to discord for sponsoring
this video and just a reminder that i
have a discord of my own
some of you are already in it and we
have lots of good conversations in there
and if you're not and you don't know
what discord is discord is a place for
communities
you can join different servers to talk
to people within different communities
that you love
for example my discord community is
based off of marvel of course
star wars dc and other awesome pop
culture news you can chat with your
friends directly or you can chat with a
bunch of people in a server
in my discord we have a huge group chat
where we talk about all the latest
marvel news we share our excitement we
share our theories we share what we
think is going to happen and we
basically just geek out all the time
together
so i know everybody loves talking marvel
just like i do so go ahead and download
discord
join my server so we can all talk
together just click the link in the
description box down below download
discord and find your community
and once you download discord find my
discord in my about me section
now we'll start off with the previous
actors returning as reported from the
illuminerty.com
both martin starr and hannibal burus are
returning as their respective characters
mr harrington
and coach wilson now neither of these
two really had that important roles as
far as their characters are concerned
but it does tell us that at some point
in time we may see peter parker back at
school
more on that in just a bit but let's
talk about the new characters that are
being casted for
right now also coming from the
illuminati.com right now spider-man 3 is
casting for
an unnamed agent as listed as either
male or female
someone that feels intimidating even if
it isn't physical
casting says the actor should ideally be
strong in theater
the crew is considering all ethnicities
and they are hoping for the character to
feel like
a new yorker the second character is for
an
unnamed detective role according to
casting the film is searching for a male
black person of color with a fluid age
range interest has been shown thus far
in michael k williams nathaniel martella
white
and marwan konzari so we have an agent
and a detective
most likely working together and both
most likely on the case of spider-man
slash peter parker
now of course after the video that
mysterio put out at the end of
spider-man fire from home
there are going to be a lot of people
that say spider-man is a murderer peter
parker is a murderer especially jay
jonah jameson
but the law does state we're innocent
until we're proven guilty
now i guess it depends on whether or not
you think mysterio recording his own
video
saying that peter parker is the murderer
is evidence enough to convict spider-man
as guilty
but he is the bad guy and he's framing
peter parker which some people
might think he's doing so there has to
be an investigation they can't just say
you're going to jail and not to mention
they have to prove that peter parker is
spider-man mysterio is just throwing
around accusations
so peter parker is going to have this
agent and this
detective on his case now we're not sure
whether or not they're trying to prove
him guilty or they're trying to prove
him innocent
they could be very one-sided thinking
that spider-man slash peter parker
is in fact a villain they just need some
good evidence to convict him
this could also be another reason why mr
harrington and coach wilson are
returning for the third film there's a
good possibility that they will
investigate them
they'll go around talking to peter
parker's friends his family his teachers
at school
asking if he's ever done anything to
make them believe that he could in fact
be spider-man or he could in fact be a
murderer
again an actual investigation has to be
held but this means that peter parker
probably isn't going to be leaving new
york
typically if they're investigating him
especially for a murder he's not going
to be able to leave
now there is a possibility that the
agent character could be working for
shield after all in spider-man far from
home peter parker
at least he thought he was working with
shield and he technically was working
with shield but it wasn't nick fairy or
maria hill
it was talos and his wife but obviously
spider-man slash peter parker has some
connections
after all he was and is an avenger so if
the local authorities are going to be
sending in a detective to investigate
the case
shield may send in one of their own
agents to help with it and prove that
peter parker is
in fact innocent now as far as how this
will tie into the multiverse aspect of
the film
it probably won't play that big of a
role at this point we're not actually
sure how universes collide or how the
other spider-man get into our universe
perhaps doctor strange helps hide
spider-man
in different universes whatever the case
may be the multiverse is definitely
going to be
a main storyline we know wanda is going
to affect the universe's reality
throwing it into chaos that's when
spider-man 3 comes along and doctor
strange is in that film of course as we
know
and all of that bleeds into doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
so the multiverse moving forward is
going to be a very big part of the
marvel cinematic universe
but as far as spider-man 3 is concerned
peter is still going to have to prove
that he's innocent
and hopefully he can convince people
that he is not
spider-man perhaps a blind lawyer who is
very good at beating people
could come in and help him out with that
situation so peter is going to have to
prove his innocence in spider-man 3.
what do you think about this in the
comments down below do you think the
agent
is from shield and do you think matt
murdock will show up as peter's lawyer
leave your thoughts down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof